I'm not going oh it takes three months
to get a reservation to this place I
just don't want to be with these people
it sounds super exclusive and sexy like
going to France during the German
occupation maybe hold on congressman
what is going on Jeff how no matter it's
private you are running for governor
nothing as precious private annual stay
private after tonight it'll all be over
mr. and mrs. Lowman have not arrived yet
yes we have go see our driver's license
I'm his brother of course right this way
I'm the only person in my family that
cares about real people
Stan running for public office elitist
self-serving just like mother raised it
look good Pope let's do this my brother
but then I don't spent quite as much
time in makeup hello yeah you and my
phone yeah I must have thought it was
mine this is long overdue we're gonna
talk tonight and put it all on the table
toast to the children to health we're
getting to this dinner in one piece
please
I love its mom your father doesn't know
about tonight and I'd like to keep it
that way nobody will ever find out if we
just keep cool dad you just on my phone
for you times so what's the subject
you know what it is it's about the boys
much do you know how much do you know
he's gonna turn us in with him he's
gonna turn us and I know these boys have
committed a lot of rhetoric crime it was
an accident
this case will never be solved but is
that what we want these are good boys
what's done is done
I'm suspending my campaign I'm going to
set the press Congress the public as a
family you make a decision like this you
also decide the future my son families
will do anything to protect each other
trying to treat you
because I love those kids and I love you
what will he become he gets away with us
we've got a nail salon massages you're
never gonna believe what's in this next
room is it a strip club what's up with
that kid a kid's 11:00 he's up